it's been a week of damage control for
the White House or some perspective on
that and other issues we turn to amber
Phillips of the Washington Post she
writes about politics for the fix
amber good morning good morning is Rudy
Giuliani right does this does this tape
prove the president did nothing wrong no
that's for the FBI to decide
I think this tape brings up two really
difficult political and legal questions
for the president and it's if Michael
Cohen this is a big if again did
anything legally problematic by paying
some of these women before the election
to help Trump win did Trump know about
it
were there other conversations that were
to be had the second political problem
for the president is what else did
Michael Cohen have taped and what might
he be sharing with the FBI
well Cohen has has certainly been seen
as the keeper of Donald Trump's secrets
he was called loyal to a fault what are
you hearing coming out of this in terms
of his willingness to cooperate yet
that's the big question right and it
certainly feels like Cohen is putting
out a lot of feelers that he's willing
to cooperate with the FBI over again a
man that he's worked for for the better
part of a decade he's giving really
ominous media interviews and social
media postings to Trump saying my
priorities to my family in my country
not the president almost speaking
directly to him exactly yeah amber let's
talk about the Helsinki summit for a
second and the backlash the president
faced after his meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin at the end of
the week we get the announcement that
that President Putin will be coming here
it's it's an interesting gesture in the
midst of the backlash that he received
what do you make of that
it's interesting I use the adjective
baffling this is a president who from a
public relations perspective makes
decisions based on how the media covers
it yeah and as you pointed out there was
near Universal backlash including in a
lot of conservative circles and yet here
he is going against the grain and saying
now let's invite Putin back it's all so
baffling from a counterintelligence
perspective because as we saw this week
his own intelligence chiefs didn't
realize that
was being invited back and and made it
clear they thought that was a bad idea
well any of this stick though I mean
this is a president many have called the
true Teflon Don will will what has
happened this past week with all of the
criticism have a lasting impact on this
president I have seen early evidence
he's still Teflon Don right now we have
a CBS poll showing 70 percent of
Republican voters like the way Trump
handled that Helsinki summit with Luton
compared to a third of Americans more
broadly that's important to point out
the base of Donald Trump support
approves of what he's done although in
among independents it's a very different
judgement in that same poll I want to
ask what kind of damage do you think
lingers with the intelligence community
with the president after after what
happened in Helsinki yeah I think the
president has demonstrated that he
really doesn't have a lot of credibility
within the intelligence community we saw
you know it was just remarkable the way
things lined up there was the Helsinki
summit and then this big intelligence
community gathering in Colorado days
later you had key members of trumps own
cabinet basically saying I didn't think
it was a good idea for him to do this
dan coats the top spy chief said you
know if trumpet ask me I wouldn't have
had him meet behind closed doors with
Putin for two hours so there's a little
bit of pushback from the intelligence
community in a way we haven't seen
before a lot to unravel still more to
come I am sure amber Phillips thank you
so much for being with us thank you